Ouhouhouh, en arrêtant d'faire pipi debouuuut,
tu recycles touuut
Salut ! Moi, c'est Jennifer. Vous vous demandez sans doute
comment je mesuis retrouvée là. En fait, je viens
vous annoncer une super nouvelle : ily a du nouveau sur Zeste de Science !
Bienvenue dans notre toute nouvelle série, dédiée
à notre planète Terre et à l'environnement.
Et qui dit "environnement" dit "fun" ! On va parler de
forêts qui brûlent, d'abeilles qui disparaissent,
de tortues qui mangent du plastique, de glaciers
qui fondent... Sauf que. Nous, on ne veut pas vous
parler de ce qui va mal, non parce qu'on
le sait que ça va mal...
-Attends, mais attends... Ça va
hyper mal tu veux dire ! J'angoisse.
Quand j'angoisse j'hyperventile. HAN ! MAIS DU COUP J'FAIS PLEIN DE CO2 !
Ouaaah....
Ok, pas de panique. Nous, on va vousemmener sur le terrain, à la rencontre des
chercheuses et chercheurs du CNRS, qui travaillentau quotidien dans toutes les disciplines pour
tenter de mieux protéger notre environnement,
dans l'espoir que notre planète redevienne un
jour un peu moins infernale.
Oh ! J'ai oublié quelque chose ! Comme ici, on est des gens très inventifs,
on a décidé de baptiser ce nouveau format, ehoui, "Un zeste pour la planète", alors à bientôt !